does the bible condone rape short answer
nah longer answer
no it's
God it's
God this is one of those popular
accusations and misconceptions that's
usually ran amongst groups like Muslims
or atheists agnostics or uh those those
people that try to claim their somewhere
in the middle they say I'm not religious
I'm more so
spiritual yeah they try to use
Deuteronomy 22 verse 28 to say that the
Bible condones and for the sake of the
video so it doesn't get flagged we're
going to use the word grape as a
substitute grape okay just follow me
just stick with me I know sensitive I
know just work with me okay so they they
say that that the Bible condones grape
it it forces a victim of grape to marry
her grapest now that can't be loving
that can't be fair so what we're going
to do here is we're going to look at the
context here and let's actually jump
straight into it and let's see if this
is actually true does the bible condone
grape and force the victim to marry her
Grapist let's see what it says here and
we're going to use the NIV version
because this is the version that a lot
of these people use to try to say that
the Bible clearly and explicitly says
that Gra is okay so we're going to use
the NIV version just for this but if out
in the country a man happens to meet a
young woman pledged to be married and
grapes her only the man who has done
this shall die uhoh do nothing to the
woman she has committed no sin deserving
death this case is like that of someone
who attacks and murders a neighbor for
the man found found the young woman out
in the country and though the betro
woman screamed there was no one to
rescue her now see we here we have a
clear example of a victim of grape and
it says that the woman has done nothing
wrong but the man who has graped her
shall be put to death God takes this so
seriously that he Compares this type of
violation to murder grape in God's eyes
is
is just like murdering an innocent an
innocent person that's how God sees it
so obviously here in the context we
already see what happens in the
situation of great but what happens when
we continue reading let's see because
now we're going to get to the point of
contention verse 28 if a man happens to
meet a virgin who is not pledged to
married to be married and grapes her and
they are discovered word huh he shall
pay her father 50 shekels of silver he
must marry the young woman for he has
violated her he can never divorce her as
long as he lives there you go boom bada
boom boom boom you see there Christians
Case Closed your Bible right there
explicitly says that the victim of great
has to marry her grapest how can a
loving God conduct such a thing condone
such an action no this is not what's
taking place here matter of fact pay
attention to the wording here it says
here if a man happens to meet a virgin
who is not pledged to be married and
grapes her and they are
disovered huh and they are discovered
now I didn't use it in the earlier
context in in the form of grape so why
here why is it that they have to be
discovered here for certain something to
happen well it's cuz it's it's really
the simple answer is this that the NIV
got this wrong the word is not grape
because actually even when you compare
the two words there these are two
different Hebrew words that's being used
in verse 25 versus verse 28 two
different Hebrew words are being used
the word in verse 28 that's being used
is
tapas which also means to manipulate or
to seduce the NIV got this wrong let me
just show you guys so you guys don't
think that I'm lying here when we go to
the Strong's Concordance we look at the
breakdown of the word and it means to
manipulate
iec's to lay hold of to capture to catch
so was she caught by force or was she
caught by manipulation was she seized by
manipulation and actually the Bible
sheds light on this especially when you
take into account what Deuteronomy is
the book of Deuteronomy the word
Deuteronomy itself it literally means
the second law take a look at this when
we look at the word the atmology of
Deuteronomy it means the second
law so what Deuteronomy is doing is it
is recounting some of the events that
have taken place when it comes to the
Israelites and they are it's recounting
the laws and the Commandments that were
given by God himself so then where would
we find this original law where would we
find the first time this law is brought
up well let's go ahead and take a look
if we go to Exodus chapter
22 and we pull this up we see where the
original law was stated Exodus 22:6 this
is where the original Law is that
Deuteronomy is repeating it says if a
man seduces a virgin who is not pledged
to be married and sleeps with her he
must pay the bride price and she shall
be his
wife do you guys see that this is the
the original Law Deuteronomy 22 is just
repeating it and expounding on it it has
nothing to do with forced seizure but it
has to do with
seduction so the first part verses 25 to
27 in Deuteronomy 22 that's dealing with
grape verses 28 and 29 that's a
different conver that's a different
topic it's not dealing with grape
anymore now it's dealing with
fornication it's dealing with seduction
which is why it said and they be
discovered matter of fact let's actually
put translations side by side when we
put translations side by side let's put
the the let's put the NIV version right
next to the KJV right left side is NIV
right side is KJV if a man finds a young
woman on the right side who is a virgin
who is not betrothed and he seizes her
and lies with her and they are found out
look they are found out they're found
together they are found together then
the man who lay with her shall give her
shall give to the young woman's father
50 shekels of silver sound familiar it's
just repeating what we read read in
Exodus 22 and she shall be his wife
because he has humbled her he shall not
be permitted to divorce her all of his
days so this is dealing with fornication
a man actually seduced a woman seized
her by manipulation seized her by
seduction they slept together outside of
marriage and because of that because
she's not a virgin anymore especially in
these days her value goes down no one's
going to want to marry her she's she's
already been defiled right and so
because of that even in light of them
committing
fornication God makes it way to where
the woman is still taken care of you
can't just Smash and pass if you slept
with her you now have to marry her and
take care of her you can't just leave
her out to dry you have to pay the bride
price you have to marry her and you
can't divorce her all of your days
God in light of her humiliation gives
her dignity and protection this is how
holy and just our God is in light of
these people coming together committing
sin so no the Bible does not condone
grape matter of fact the punishment for
grape is death God equates grape with
murder murdering an innocent person so
for anyone who's trying to say that the
Bible condones great and that God is not
love Ling ask them what what are we
doing here
man come on man oh my God logic
[Music]